boston dynamics robots are now doing
parkour and it is absolutely terrifying
boston dynamics was in the news earlier
this year when south korean automaker
hyundai acquired an 80 stake in the
company from softbank valuing the
company at 1.1 billion you remember
boston dynamics had been bought by
google and then flipped because google
employees i believe
were not stoked about military customers
especially not for robotics i think
that's un-american
by the employees of google who benefit
from being americans and protected by
our military for google to not support
our military i think is
i wouldn't say treasonous but i think
it's quite un-american i think if you're
an american company and you benefit from
this company and our military and the
fine people who work in our military you
should build on the technology they need
to protect your ass because when things
go down you can be sure google employees
would want to be protected and google
shareholders i'm going to put that aside
for a second because it is their right
in america to not service the military
but on tuesday boston dynamics tweeted
the following along with a video of
their robots doing
not kidding parkour parkour is the
perfect sandbox for the atlas team to
experiment with new behaviors through
jumps balance beams and vaults we push
atlas to its limits to discover the next
generation of mobility perception and
athletic intelligence wow when you watch
this video and i'm playing it right now
as we're talking
it is truly terrifying you have this
robot
doing all kinds of jumps across boxes
and tables and pieces of plywood that
are angled very difficultly maybe a 15
degree angle and then doing backflips
off of like really high roofs and
balance beams and then a second one
comes and runs along the balance beam
this stuff is insane
the backflip of course is the
the best part the dexterity is
mind-boggling one of them leaps over
using its hand as a prop
the balance beam and then they both
turn around and do a backflip
from basically double backflips from two
robots in perfect unison
and the first one's off of a three and a
half foot desk onto a maybe an 18-inch
box and then off of that and then they
flat pumping their fists
if you look at this i don't know if
you've seen the terminator movies in a
while but i took my daughter to see
terminator 2 when the pandemic ended
they were playing some because they were
out of movies they were playing some
classic movies i went to the theater
literally i kid you not we were two of
two people in the theater and we saw
terminator 2. and they're walking across
basically uh work torn city i think it's
los angeles and they're walking across
debris and rubble of
buildings
it's
less
challenging than what those robots just
did the only difference is those robots
aren't holding guns
and you can be certain that robots can
hold guns and you can be certain that
certain military organizations have
robots today holding guns
now google and boston dynamics not might
not be willing to do that for our
government but i am certain that south
korea's government bought boston
dynamics so that they can have these
robots holding guns because they have
north korea ready to
basically cross the border
and annihilate them with a crazy leader
at any point in time and i don't blame
the south koreans they should have
bought boston dynamics they should put
guns on these things if i was living
there and i want and i had north korea
as my neighbor i would want a million of
these robots on the border ready to go
if you think this through you can go
onto
the youtube and you can find
different folks playing with their
drones
and putting paintball guns on etc i i
think this is the future of the military
not just drones that are airplanes like
the small quadcopter drones here is a
t-cad drone this is made by duke
robotics and it is a remotely operated
firing-enabled drone developed for the
us military now this looks pretty janky
but it's obviously going to work they
just strapped it so it looks a military
rifle onto the bottom of this drone they
didn't make a purpose made gun it looks
like this is just a gun floating in the
air shooting at people this is going to
end a skirmish pretty quick if we had
these for with the taliban in
afghanistan
i think we would be able to put up a
heck of a resistance i think the they
would have run for the hills
we didn't have to send troops in and we
sent this in uh in an article by design
boom they say the robot is adapting its
behavior based on what it sees by
repeating the parkour exercises by this
no pre-programming of all possible
motions is required but instead the team
defined a smaller set of behavior
templates that can be related to the
environment this is a fancy way of
saying
that this
robot hasn't exactly been programmed to
do that course that would be one level
of impressive that's saying they taught
robot heuristics basic rules and how to
navigate them so if you were to go into
that course and move stuff around and
say to the robot run around
the concept here is they would be able
to adapt and do it which anybody who
owns a commercial drone knows because
when the drones land or when they are
going to fly into a tree they can they
have avoidance systems now they're not
completely intelligent you can't just
talk to your commercial drone and say
hey go fly find somebody shoot them and
come back and if it can be built with
today's technology fairly easily that
means the military has this already
here's a quadcopter it's got a gun on it
here are if you remember from the iraqi
war we had the deck of cards with all
the bad guys on it
they could just put the deck of cards in
there do facial recognition you see the
person headshot done that's coming folks
and this is the world we live in okay if
this has been too dystopian for you some
good news disney is getting into
sentient robots westworld is coming
hopefully without the same outcome
teams today need a central hub for their
information and work more than ever
especially in a world of remote work
that's where notion comes in it's one
place for your notes your documents your
projects and everyday work that goes
well beyond a wiki so when we went fully
remote in march of 2020 here at launch
and this week in startups notion became
our internal knowledge bank look at the
video here while one of my producers
goes through our pod notes page on
notion where we highlight the top
lessons from every episode we also put
the ad copy that i'm reading in notion
right now how meta is that additionally
all of the investments we do we will put
videos we'll put our due diligence
everything is on notion as i tell people
when you're talking to me about a
project i want a notion page notion is
the one place where every team from
engineering to sales can work together
seamlessly with 500 integrated apps
including google and slack which we have
integrated and it works great hundreds
of thousands of teams worldwide are
already delighting their employees with
notion plus notion has a worldwide
community of millions of users creating
templates and tutorials so the product
is continually improving so you go to
notion.so that's right notion. and use
the promo code twist you're going to get
250 off their annual team plan think
about that 250
it's an incredibly generous offer if you
don't have notion you're wasting so much
time i love the product congratulations
to the team there i am addicted to
notion okay let's get back to this
episode